okay for those who are joining us on the
live stream this is another episode in
real life
software design this is discussing
features for the upcoming version of
Wolfram language this is a miscellaneous
box our incremental language development
effort so let's get started so sequence
replaces first on the on our list so
there we have discussed this in the past
and there is an asymmetry between the
sequences from the left and sequences on
the right and we are not sure yet of
what to choose on the right hand side
whether to have an additional level
level of list or not and there are
several advantages and disadvantages in
both so so the issue is ogz triple blank
that that thing represents the list then
the odd is going to bind to the sequence
and then this is going to say turn that
into a list but that's replace notation
so so in sequence replace the question
is whether yes so so we will have a list
representing a sequence on the left hand
side the question is whether we want
that list also on the right hand side
can really the current implementation
does not have it so we want to splice a
sequence on there on the right hand side
then we have to use egg explicitly
sequence okay so wait a minute so can we
see an actual example here I mean is
this some yes the documentation that I
guess that's why say we wanted
okay so what he's saying here is a
sequence replace this goes to e exactly
and so we don't have to say least e on
the right hand side I don't think we
should have to but now the issue is if E
is a sequence there exactly if he is
bound to a double blank or something
what does it do and the answer is
knowing what it should do is to splice
it it doesn't it I mean it did it
naturally splices it what we have to use
sequence right sugar yes why oh I see
because you have to collect I see what
you're saying in other words if the
right hand side destination represents a
multiple object oh boy that's a mess yes
and if we didn't have all the sequence
functions then we would just I don't
think we have this thing in X kernel yet
right okay okay but so the issue is that
why do you have a point of view about
this no I haven't deep enough and
sequenced replace really have an opinion
okay if if this function was alone I
would vote for having a list on the
right-hand side as well what shibir has
pointed out here on the left is that we
have other sequence functions and not
having that list Alliance sequence
replays better with the other function
sequence cases on the future sequences
split okay see where we met sequence
cases does what in that situation so
sequence cases will return so if I do
sequence cases of this and I say for
example just you know X double blank
here yeah well what's a good example
Sharia of having that rule on the right
hand side actually let's do this X blank
Y blank X blank actually XY double blank
that why
trouble blank there why does it only
give one of these maybe there is only
one in that list let me just put in
something else another case here okay
yes so now if we wanted to replace that
sequence by something else we would use
a list on the second Aria rule in the
second argument yes so let's say we want
to replace it by that what on earth is
that doing that is pretty wild I mean if
I were to so if I replace that by F of Y
okay mm-hmm so in that first case it's a
sequence the head is a sequence and it's
Auto splicing yes so did I guess the
main point is that we don't have to use
an explicit list on the right hand side
always right and and that's what you're
proposing is the same as would happen in
sequence replace exactly so that it will
become us an auto splicer so to speak I
mean and one of the issues there is if
you wanted to have multiple things that
spliced then the only way to do that
here will be to have a sequence on the
right hand side yes I think there are
there is some example in the in the
reference page so I mean for example
here we could say sequence yyy and then
it will splice like that yeah well I I
think we have to have consistency with
this I don't really see how we can avoid
doing that yeah
okay does anybody does anyone want to
argue for the for the idea that you have
lists on the right-hand side of sequence
replace
somebody's asking so if we can zoom our
notebooks a bit well sure we can zoom in
a bit I think we didn't need to actually
I thought this was some I thought we had
beautiful reproduction of um I'm gonna
go to 125 percent I'm afraid not to
hundred percent because otherwise we
don't get enough on the screen um I hope
that's better
um okay go ahead
um so yeah I'm I'm recently also more in
favor of the first option the one we
have currently implemented okay fine
let's go for it I I think there's really
no choice
I think we've we've cooked that
particular goose already with the other
functions there's the only thing about
sequence split that we should be aware
of in this regard know very similar to
sequence okay alright let's move on okay
I started looking at oh my gosh what on
earth is this cuz I send in my proposals
for other curry names I don't think so
so in the last meeting you asked us to
generate this list of related names so
that we get some inspiration of possible
connection let's not spend this whole
meeting talking about names of curry I I
actually had some ideas I think take a
look I think I made some notes on my own
here to take a look that's W only okay
so I was thinking about things like
first of all I think
currying function is better than curry
if we really have to go that route it is
a currying function because I think we
will
fused about his curry curry run curry
but I'm sort of you know that there are
different cases here because there's
this case the default case we're all
we're doing is to have that single you
know where the main objective is just
first becomes lost type thing where we
have something of the form you know
curry partition you know three range of
ten this is that case there where that
is a very specific one earth happened to
that oh that's because we flipped curry
now right do we think we want that I
don't even know how we do this now how
do we do this do we do two one yeah
ie I think we introduce a curry second
okay so so what's the last name we yeah
well I mean I think we're gonna need to
name that that second operation doesn't
up these are deeply obscure I mean
deeply deeply obscure I was thinking
about you know these things what we call
it ourselves as an operator form usually
Jim and I think it's a little weird to
call it operator I mean if you saw in a
piece of code you know operate or off
partition I don't know whether it will
help you very much I don't think so and
I think it would be a waste of such an
important name yeah I agree
yeah that was the point I was going to
make I think there are many other things
we'd want to call operator before that
right
so there's also applicator whatever that
might mean I mean the notion that it is
doing something to do with function
application seems useful to capture in
the name and
you know applied or something some weird
thing like that I mean you know if we
named it something like applicator it's
pretty weird it has a certain sense of
you know cosmetics products or something
like this um which is kind of crazy um
but I mean we again we got to really be
thinking what does this thing actually
do you know the name that I had for this
kind of construct in SMP tear other than
the fact that it's a crazy
unpronounceable kind of weird word is I
mean you know it is the it is the thing
that is going between you know that type
of form and the ferox form I mean that
would be one way to describe it you know
I don't know how it will be lovely if we
could find a description of this that
wasn't you know as obscures the as a
curry word some some words continuum
bracket yeah I think you were suggesting
that I mean it the Dee bracketed or
something but that just seems it's a
structural but but it goes to the point
of what this function is or it's a
function related thing where you're
basically saying you know it's look one
thing is one argument at a time this is
I mean that's why an SMP thirty seven
eight years ago or something
I had this named tier which is you know
is the thing in multiple tiers or is it
all in one go so to speak that's what
I'm saying yeah is it sort of a
hierarchy of function applications um I
don't know
I mean I'm gonna see Christopher
tomorrow and I he's somebody who might
have a good idea about this I'm gonna
bug him about this let's let's let's not
let's not burn up our whole meeting with
this today so let's some let's good
let's continue I think that was we've
got to solve that problem obviously but
it's just the name okay so do do we have
her nude not yet so he wanted to attend
this conversation of tokenize so let's
give him a bit more time let's go to the
next one this man taking port okay yes
so these I think this is an important
suggestion which is basically what's an
easy way to provide headings for a
dataset so yeah that is a good question
so if we have this happens even for a
metric so it will have a matrix and we
want to construct a data set with given
headings both columns and rows what's a
good way of doing it right good question
okay is there somebody here who wants to
talk about that or do we have a I mean I
understand that there's anybody anybody
from this list here or are we making
this up ourselves you know special
constructor forms for data sets I mean I
guess this is a slightly different I
mean this is this is I mean what you
have just typed in is a different
question than what's here which is the
question here is there's already row and
column headings in the matrix and you
just want to label them as such hold on
visit there's a multiple cases here so
one case is yeah the one that was
discussed in the thread is the one I
just mentioned okay what could you
repeat that one so you already have rows
and column headings in your data the
other that's you know spreadsheet you're
importing or whatever and you want to
preserve them preserve them right so to
my mind what that should be is a data
set import so if I say file dot CSV my
claim is that that's what should happen
if you do this now I know and I just
failed to see it in the in the meeting
right before this one there's a bunch of
updates to the CSV importer I don't know
whether they've done this so you're
telling me if I have a spreadsheet and
and I say data set it will import the
headings headings I don't know but it
that's the question okay I told me if I
have a CSV file
let's take a look whether there's an
example CSV father by the way by the way
could you point out to somebody that in
eleven point three X kernel the all the
documentation is opening with its with
everything yeah you see what you see
that was reported like a week or two ago
I don't know why it's not fixed yet okay
all right fine so okay so the question
here is I mean both in import and export
can we ask maybe we can find those
working on on doing what Shawn is
working on it I'm asking him ok can we
join gonna get him to join ok so anyway
so that's the first thing is making sure
that when there is a and you know an
outside source that has labels on the
rows and columns that we preserve those
right yeah like that was what you were
saying there well not necessarily an
outside things but well what will be an
inside thing that has these well you've
created yes I agree this is a case where
I'd love to be able to do that January
February March April whatever as the as
the column labels and how would I do
that right right because what that is
going to turn into is a nested
Association of associations and that's
kind of a weird operation for us right
now so I haven't think in a bit about
this I think what we need is some sort
of mixture between threading and folding
so imagine that we have a function that
takes the first argument is rule the
second is a list of headings at
different levels and the third is the
array and that returns already all these
nested rules already organized at the
various levels okay so let's let's
understand what you're proposing so this
is essentially what we're doing is we're
representing the indices in each level
right so this thing here has ended C's
one two three four five right so what we
are defining is a mapping from those
indices to some Association indices for
example I would claim so what would we
call such a then go ahead then Shauna's
here okay great
okay uh and he's got the correct term
session yep
Shawn I used since hey can you hear me
yep okay so we had a question actually
okay we'll come back just let me okay
look back it we're talking about CSV
importers and preserving column and row
headings on those but let's just discuss
one more thing so does anybody have a
potential name for the function so this
function blah blah blah is going to take
essentially one thing it could take is a
list of lists for each level of label
label one label two for the first level
label one label two for the second level
etc is that correct or alternatively it
could take lists of rules here that um
that apply differently okay so what
who's selling this at are you sending
yes and so this is a thread from me if
you've created your own matrix and you
want to so this is this is the piece of
data and what you want to do is to turn
that into an association right and
here's the code and a couple of
different ways to take the code and turn
it into an association you want okay oh
yeah yeah that's pretty old nature okay
yeah so and what I said you know we
probably want something like you know a
second argument row headings column
headings for what for for these cases
right where it just tells it you know
treat the first row as as an example
what's it one of those options - there
are not options there second
there are second arguments to dataset
what does data set right now do for its
second argument it doesn't it doesn't
have one I don't think right so I see so
what you're suggesting is that there is
a which argument what that we do have a
second argument in the full form but
it's a type but it's that useful we can
think of yes that's just so long as we
have compatibility mechanisms for that
and anyway we've been poor and hopefully
you're greatly improving it so if you
have on you know the maintainability of
data set across sessions and so on but
but look I think this is a pretty common
case that you see stuff like this but I
would be I will be prepared to imagine
you know a to argument form what on
earth will be called such a function I
think we need to hear something more
powerful that works I mean if we need
one of these functions that takes an F
energy like like inner like a we need
that some sort of multi-level version of
inner so what I would call this
something like full threat it's it's a
mixture of folding on thrilling oh gosh
okay and then it will take an an F
function which in this case is rule it's
going to create rules then your list of
labels then the array and then
Association so imagine the generality of
this and then come association right
well I still I would argue that doesn't
actually solve the problem no it's an
interesting function but we need a we
need more icing on that cake I think yes
yeah yeah you know that may such a
function may or may not actually be
useful because I mean if you can use
this function you may be able just to
just write it directly using inner like
Sean did here or but it just doesn't
solve the problem I just want to declare
that my data has column headings
in my data set no I understand I
understand so but the the question only
the other question is creating something
it isn't a data set and it's just a
bunch of nested you know associations
right so the issue is to turn a an
ordinary array
or perhaps an association with different
labels but let's start off with an
ordinary array what would be the way do
we have any way of turning what will be
the way that we would turn that thing
into an association with a B and C as
they as the names association threat but
it only works at the one level
okay so association thread of this with
ABC right yes I think one single level
of list like this yeah okay yes so now
why would Association thread not take
some kind of levels back well because if
this works like thread or or mat thread
somehow you need to replicate tons of
times
the day the labels on the left-hand side
okay I get it
so really this is a I mean this is
something for in a sense full arrays
where the same labels are going to be
used many times right exactly that's not
sort of folding here there is something
that is being picked one at a time needs
that notion I mean in in a sense
don't we have notions when we're dealing
with sparse arrays and so on don't we
have notions that are you know different
depending on whether we're dealing with
a full array where every because
essentially what what what we're dealing
with here is that this thing is going to
be replicated into every row right for
example in a multi dimensional thing
that is replicated into every row
because effectively what what is
happening a way to think about it is
we're simply renaming the indices
instead of that being row index two it's
row index B yes but that's the case for
example notice that this association
thread is automatically adding rule
there without uh specifying anywhere
whether we want that rule or relate or
something else so it's fully crazy idea
okay the idea would be a thing called
index replace
we're by the way we have a something of
an echo here somebody I don't know who's
going here I I think Sean might be
implicated because he joined when the
echo got appeared but okay the crazy
idea here would be I mean this isn't
quite right but something like the first
we try to get rid of this echo um I
can't hear an echo but I'm on you okay
um yeah I can't okay well let's not
worry about it
okay so then then the proposal would be
something like this where what that
means where the full version of that
would be something like this would be
one arrow a two arrow B etc am i making
sense so that's saying take the indices
at successive levels and map them into
these things here so for example if you
want one level to be purely um you know
you could have a level B automatic which
means just use the same you know just
use the indices that came in from the
original array so this is going to turn
the array into an association
association of associations association
this this thing here would turn it into
that will be the level one that's level
two right and that's saying those are
the rows those are the columns and this
is now relay relabeling everything
according to those you know those
indices I mean I think this is as a
concept this is fairly easy to
understand yes I'm I'm worried about the
name so if it's the name may be wrong
okay go ahead what were you gonna say if
it's going to return associations then
Association should be in the name it
isn't necessarily going to return
associations you can imagine well maybe
it is
associations I agree um yeah I mean this
is I mean I I was thinking you could
imagine with automatic for example it
might not in fact you could even imagine
if you used automatic there but it could
turn associations into lists because
automatic would just say get rid of all
those association labels and just
flatten it out into a straight list did
that make sense
good being sorted so I would expect our
automatic perhapses keep whatever it has
and perhaps we have okay I would like to
remove them like nine or yeah you're
right you're right none would be better
that yep you're right okay but so so
does this achieve I mean this as an
operation is something I've certainly
wanted a bunch of times um I mean it's a
little weird you know arguably in the
case of a single list it should work on
you know the single list case should be
the same should be this case here that
labels the columns next rename index
what would you call this so I'm thinking
that this is ready two keys and
Association so some re-keying three I
should or could it be an extension of
Association thread let's remind
ourselves how Association thread works I
don't think so would be my guess I think
Association thread
[Music]
I'm sort of partial to this idea that
you can remap keys I mean which would
suggest some kind of rekey but that's
really obscure I mean this is obscure as
well because this is basically I mean
this is um you know make things into use
keys for these I don't know um
index key other people have other
thoughts about this I was wondering if
we also wanted some symbolic
representation of the headers instead of
a symbol that actually do the
computation okay and this could be fed
to any visualization symbol that we have
I don't know table form or data set so
we really keep the same well in a sense
we have that here right I mean the
problem with all of those things is what
if there are more elements I mean right
here I haven't addressed the question if
I only gave three labels what happens if
it's a four by four array and the thing
about replace is that it is somewhat
natural in that case because what we
would do is if it's missing something
then it would just be for for example it
would just be the original underlying
you know non-association key name if you
get what I'm saying do we have a key
replace ring I don't think we I don't
know if we do why is this not working
well I can go here
okay let's try key replace we certainly
don't have key replace
we don't I think it's a little obscure
he replaced because I think what this is
doing as you say it is turning things
typically into associations array to
Association Association arrey arrey
association something like array
Association is not Knut's so these would
be a particular case of the function I
was suggesting before with the first
argument rule and the last argument
Association okay let me walk through
that here let me let me save this
somewhere um switch where I'm gonna save
this where should I save this notes and
then what I'm going to since we don't
have a name for the function yes this is
a little hard to name I don't think we
have a miscellaneous function we have a
miscellaneous section look at that I'm
gonna put it under miscellaneous I can
never ever find it here but you'll have
to remember where it is yes yes and
let's call it association array because
that's the best thing I've seen so far
okay actually no I'm gonna call it fold
thread because that's the most general
thing I've seen so far okay so let's
understand your fault thread proposal
for a second okay so it's arguments are
so it takes a function f then it takes a
list of labels okay let's call it it's
basically first arguments
okay and then it will be the second
arguments which is the attack
yeah and energy okay and then what this
is going to do is it will go level by
level of the second arguments and
construct the F of first argument comma
second argument yes I understand
and how does it know okay so it's
mapping down I I don't claim I claim it
something more why is it folding because
it's is taking one of the first
arguments at each level but it's so it
will consider for the first level of
second arguments it will take the first
listing first arguments for the second
level of second arguments it will take
the second listing secondary but unlike
fold which is generating kind of this
screamer of stuff
this is generating a hierarchy of things
isn't it in a sense yes I mean I claim
this is more like a map thread type play
how does this differ from map thread
because map thread will consider the
same level of first argument and second
argument at each time well here we want
the first element of first arcs with the
first level of second are I suit you
saying okay so what this is is this is a
this is okay so this is a map thread
where yeah I mean it's it's the
difference between indices where it's
looking at elements of first dogs rather
than levels of first dogs exactly
and that's the same deal as this index
replaced thing is also the same same
idea because it's basically doing index
work so to speak yeah yeah all right
yeah the functions do we have where
where we are going down Amina since we
could imagine a version of map that does
this right you could imagine a version
of map
okay so map indexed right in a sense is
doing a simple version of this right map
index Tube exper is but now you could
imagine a how many arguments does map
indexed actually have three just a level
spec okay so you could imagine a version
of map indexed where you'd say map f X
per level spec and then you could say
[Music]
level Lev items so in other words
instead of just feeding in you know we
could do the exact same thing as here we
could we could say that could be a
mapping of the indices so what I'm
saying so instead of saying so there
what we could do is at level one instead
of the indices one two three we'd be
feeding in ABC as the second arguments
of F am I making sense and somebody is
sending me a chat i know'd I gotta tell
you whenever you send a chat which has
multiple lines in it the silliness of
zoom causes those multiple lines to not
be copyable know you should send it by
email if you want if you want three
lines sorry I just can't copy this I
mean it's some well I guess I could copy
each line I'm copy everything each line
separately it's kind of a that's
possible I'm hold on that's some okay so
let's look at this
okay great um okay so you say keys value
list okay yeah well I think that's what
we're dealing with here
yeah we're you were asking for different
idioms I think we're different ways of
thinking about it this is how I
typically think about it and how I do it
if I if I need to get something like
that
yes but the how do you handle several
levels at the same time
I usually don't because I don't yeah
right I mean so what you want is you
want this kind of index replace the
thing I mean this is exactly what it
with might I mean I don't particularly
the name index replaces a little weird
what do you think about Association
array as a name for this well not sure
what has to do with array it's working
on two names that represent two super
fundamental objects together and that's
it's kind of confusing yeah right in the
end result is if data set so maybe data
set should be part of there well it's
not obvious that the end result needs to
be a data said it could be an array I
mean the fact that this is turning into
a data set is a different thing and
maybe that is what we want I mean it
very common case it's like you have a
CSV file and you want to you know I know
I know I know I know I know the only
cousin typically right but it I has
suggested that this actually be an
argument to data set the mapping so I
think we want a separate function that
just does this
maybe I'm worried that data set is going
to need all kinds of other tentacles
particularly when we get to vertical
virtual data sets that have backing from
outside databases and things like this
um what about having our options for
leadership to take this like like the
tables heading sensing possibility yes
I mean table headings basically does
does this and that's option that you
know it's an option from 30 years ago
but then you have to you know if it has
the table having already in them you
have to excise them what has the table
headings already in them if the data
already has the headings in them you'll
have to excise them right for what
purpose
because table headings adds headings it
does not it doesn't it doesn't allow you
to declare what to use as heading no I
declare positions which are headings it
allows you to add theta which is which
are new heading yeah I get it right
hey listen we've got Sean here Kent I
want to know the answer to the question
did did we implement for this version
import of a CSV as a data set yes an
11-2 and so when there are headings in
the data set in the CSV or rather in the
XLS file if there are headings in the
XLS file what does it do well it we
haven't done this for XLS yet we only
have it for CSV and in CSV you really
just have you know your flat 2d data and
you can interpret like your first row as
a heading and how does it specify that
with an option header lines where is
that option header lines number of lines
to assume as headers so if I say header
lines and I say import as a data set
here yep then what happens if I have two
lines of headings and I want to import
us a data set does it make a list or
something for every what does it do it
basically just uses the two lines
combined how does it combine them as a
list with our new line basically it's
basically string joining them I guess
with the new line
yeah it's a little weird does does that
also does header lines also allow for
row headings or just column heading
both yes under the option you specify
with a list for the number of rows and
the number of columns to take n rows to
skip weight net wouldn't it be by
default oh I see so they have data that
there's no notion of a header so it just
skips no I understand but what this is
saying if I say one their head aligned
zero one it's going to take the top row
and treat it as a bunch of column labels
right yes okay I mean that's another
operation that seems not completely
useless for us to have which is more
similar to your map thread or Ray
Association thread thing which is to
take something which has already got a a
list in there and kind of turn it into
so let's oh look there are two
operations that seem useful given a
collection of labels insert them in
collection of labels for each level
insert them everywhere okay that's one
one case another case is given a quotes
composite array
use first rows columns etc as labels
that right
yes that that's an interesting different
thing
right so that's the case of so to give
an example of that case somebody had I
think was it at I had given that example
up here yes this one here right that's
this case okay and then this one is
rather this case okay
so and here by the way I mean we could
have I mean this is basically headers to
keys it's roughly what that's doing am i
right
I'm thinking of this similar thing with
fold in which when we have only one list
we decide that the first element is
going to be this argument that we
separate as a special Oh interesting yes
well again let me come back to your fold
that your thing which I don't believe is
correctly named just fold thread yeah
and thinking that perhaps it's more like
like a nest right unfold is a nest
it's a nesting of thread yeah based in
also we've got I mean we've got this
thing here where map indexed I mean
where we couldn't principle be
relabeling I'm sorry what are you saying
that this thing is this thing is a nest
of map indexed that's what you're saying
something like that a nesting of
mozzarella in a folding of moths right
and thinking about your previous comment
in which you were saying this is getting
insight again and again yeah yeah yeah
right so this one here the first
arguments here would be things like you
know ABC you know we'll just write out a
b c XY like right the second argument is
some kind of array
and what was the G here the G is leased
or Association basically or in light
function
I see realistically that there will be
like Association and this would be like
rule here excellent okay and a principle
there's also a level spec here yes it
could go up to some level for example
rather than all levels
exactly yeah right because they might
want to take sub lists somewhere okay so
again I need to go in a moment here
unfortunately let's let's look this is
case here so but by the way the answer
from Shawn was basically yes he's
already done this so that's great are
there good examples and the
documentation for this thing and also
Shawn could you make sure that Chris
Carlson knows for the work flows about
importing spreadsheets to put in
something about this yeah sure there are
examples yes good oh yeah I see one
right here you know nice okay well
that's great
okay so you already did this although
hopefully you can also do it for XLS
where it can be much more automatic well
we're with XLS if you just give dataset
is that in the works or is that not yet
I am working on data set with Excel
right now yeah great okay all right one
last what do you mean by more automatic
if I may well that you don't have to
give had a line so in other words if
they excel file am I going crazy or is
it does Excel not distinguish does Excel
the sting wish could you tell ya think
of an easy way to tell if this thing is
mo kPa away strings versus numbers for
example right if you've got a
spreadsheet where there's a row of
strings and then everything else is an
array of numbers that's pretty much a
dead giveaway isn't it
it seems pretty obvious I wonder about
performance um yes well no I mean that
that's a that's a simple heuristic I
think you should try and understand that
right because I mean yeah
in most cases you've imported right you
know what this is easy to do because
right you import and after importing
even if what you do is to check the
first couple of lines right say oh
they're all numbers you know first line
it's all strings for second line it's
all numbers okay and then you say well
okay let me go check the rest of it and
you can pretty quickly check that it's
all numbers and this is for just the
data set element yeah that's correct
so is this an option that can be turned
off sure yes you can turn this off okay
I mean although you're never gonna want
to never ever ever going to want to it's
always going to do what you want and
rating I mean just that's what I think I
think I mean not imagining look there
are really wacky spreadsheets where
people have written you know random
notes to their dogs on the you know top
three rows of the spreadsheet right yeah
I mean and then we have to know whether
that's and so there's a whole kind of
machine learning adventure which I don't
think we've embarked on yet to try to
actually find the data inside the
spreadsheet so to speak I'll also add
the mechanisms to do it yourself so I
mean you could skip those first few rows
and then use the next one as a header
sure and that's the data set you get
Yeah right absolutely
okay last moment here what are we going
to call this thing I mean headers to
keys yeah I don't really like that very
much but but what that this operation is
definitely an interesting operation this
one here so index rename I mean how will
people think about it
like that but associate ice all right we
already have to associate so nobody have
over ideas okay
to be continued that's let's sum I mean
this is a really good function and we
need to have it we just need to figure
out what it should be called and I think
still on the table is a ties proposal
that this be a second argument or second
option to two data set but I think it
should be a separate function probably
all right very good
thanks all I guess the old soon thinking
things talk to you later bye